ils sont plus de 2500 québécois en
attente d'obtenir justice devant les
tribunaux
qu'ils soient autochtones ou non c'est
le cas de guettant bégin dans les années
50 il aurait été agressée sexuellement à
de nombreuses reprises par le curé de sa
paroisse aux nouveaux cheminements volé
mon enfance on a détruit une grande
partie de ma vie aujourd'hui l'homme de
82 ans demandent au pape françois de
s'excuser publiquement à toutes les
victimes québécoises de l'église
catholique lors de son passage à québec
les franchises jury pour moi toutes les
victimes toutes les vics nous ne voulons
pas que la condition
des victimes de prêtres pédophiles passe
sous le radar est que le pape françois
retourne au vatican sans avoir été
informé dans une lettre des victimes des
victimes alléguées et leurs avocats
demandent au pape de négliger personne
l'archevêque de québec confirme en avoir
pris connaissance je me ferais messager
en apportant personnellement cette
lettre au saint père
le fil conducteur de sa visite sera le
chemin vers la vérité la justice la
guérison la réconciliation l'espérance
j'espère que ce thème pourra toucher les
personnes très largement écrit le
cardinal cyprien lacroix par communiqué
il indique allait remettre la lettre au
pape je sais pas avais tu roules à
l'être dans la pile de documents qu'ils
veuillent donner mais c'est certain que
notre interlocuteur c'est pour supprimer
la croix mais les excuses ne doivent pas
venir seul pour les victimes la guérison
passe aussi par la réparation faut que
ça ait d'autres percussions que des
répercussions financières dans les
hôtels dans les restaurants faut aussi
que ça ait des répercussions auprès des
principales personnes intéressées qui
sont les victimes de prêtres pédophiles
les avocats accusent non seulement des
diocèses et des congrégations
religieuses québécoise de faire preuve
de mauvaise foi à ma connaissance il n'y
a jamais eu victoire de l'église
catholique dans des locaux collectifs
mais aussi d' obstruction d'allonger les
délais devant les tribunaux et d'aller à
l'encontre de l'intérêt des victimes le
pape a pourtant souvent affirmé qu'il
fallait reconnaître leur souffrance tout
ce que le peuple depuis des mois des
années mais ça descend encore dans les
cours de justice ça descend pas dans les
diocèses guettant bégin tente d'obtenir
réparation auprès du diocèse de québec
depuis 2006 il est de tout coeur avec
les victimes des pensionnats autochtones
mais il ne veut pas être oubliés ici
marie pierre mercier radio canada québec